all right another friday another video
talking about mando
also spoiler warning for this episode of
mando and previous episodes of mandel
you know you've been warned as always
it's hard to talk about these episodes
and not talk about spoilers and yeah
this episode has them without the
spoilers i'd be like so baby yoda sat on
a rock
and storm troopers and stuff for a
boring video that would be so okay where
we left off ahsoka said all right take
the child
to this place this rock and sit him on
the rock
and if the other jedi out there they'll
hear the call
which that is a correction i need to
make when i first heard it i kind of
heard
it as her going there other jedi out
there and they'll hear him when in
reality she said
it's possible for other jedi to hear him
basically insinuating if they're out
there they'll hear him
maybe and that's maybe if they're even
out there so she doesn't really know at
first i was like how many other jedi are
there i know she's not a jedi she has
professed it many times but that's the
gist that show up on this planet he's
like i don't know does this look jedi to
you i was like dude they're big rocks
stacked among other big rocks to form
rocks that are ominously looming over a
domed rock
in the middle in the form of an altar it
looks like a structure that's
from the movie crawl yeah i'm pretty
sure you've hit the call center of the
jedi so hey
sit there baby yoda and make a call
mando sits baby grogu there
and he's like all right kid make the
call then you see the slave one come
down
and he's like ah danger let's go to work
it's funny that he
the first thing he thought was oh that's
bad news i don't know it could have been
some farmer there to pick
berries he didn't know someone was there
to cause trouble anyhow turns out to be
tamara morrison as boba fett he's teamed
up
with ming nguyen's character whom he
saved that was actually him
those were his feet that walked up to
her so people who said hey that's boba
fett
props you called it and he was like that
boba fett oh i guess i wouldn't call it
that armor that you got off of timothy
oliphant who was the sheriff who was a
sheriff at everything so of course he
played the sheriff in the mandalorian
that armor belongs to me
it belonged to my father django before
me and i'm a simple man trying to make
my way in the galaxy like my father i
was like no boba fett
your father was a simple man trying to
make his way in the universe
he was much larger scale anyhow storm
troopers come
down while baby yoda's dialing in i
don't just mean dialing in i don't mean
like oh hey
i sent a tweet no he's dialing in how we
all remember dialing in when we tried to
sneak a titty pic
when our parents weren't home or weren't
looking
[Music]
it's gonna be a second amanda's like
well at least they're just storm
troopers
and you know what he was thinking oh boy
leftovers
because that's all you can think when
you see stormtroopers just lambs to the
slaughter and
so boba fett and mando they go to work
they team up pretty sweet to see not
gonna lie glad to see that
and yeah these stormtroopers just get
slaughtered which i suppose that's aided
in the fact that mando's armor is pretty
god mode as we've seen i mean
that metal deflects lightsabers so there
is that so
blaster bolts don't stand a chance but
he's always getting shot just like bam
beep beep
[Music]
got to work on these sites what was
their danger what were you scared
also gaffy sticks are pretty sweet boba
fett has the caffeine stick
whenever he'd crack a stormtrooper the
armor would just shatter i always saw
gaffy sticks as like this warrior stick
if a warrior stick had erectile
dysfunction turns out yeah they're
pretty badass but undeniably the money
shot is seeing
boba fett in his armor i mean he doesn't
have all of it you know the pants are
different
sure but for the most part and he just
wrecked which that's the new thing in
star wars when someone's being badass
they have to shoot something without
looking at him wait boba fett's being
awesome but did he shoot a stormtrooper
without looking at him bam
there you go then moth gideon's like
okay well uh
we wasted a lot of time with those
stormtroopers why do we even still have
them because we have dark troopers send
in the dark troopers to get the
child which again if you call dark
troopers i didn't know
really what i was looking at to some of
you out there in my comment section you
called dark troopers
and they are indeed dark troopers dark
troopers come down with their jet packs
and they land
and then they get exponentially slower
like their flight path is pretty fast
and they land
like let's get them like
you probably should have landed a few
feet closer to him would have saved you
a minute and a half doesn't matter
because they get
little baby yoda and they fly off with
him and it's sad there's
a man there's something about it first
of all he was all adorable sleeping
there
and then the dark troopers just couldn't
happen boba fett tries to follow and
then he's like
that's an imperial star destroyer i'm
not doing that also mando sorry about
your ship ya mando ship just got
wasted from orbit i've always wondered
that why the empire doesn't do that more
a star destroyer will be
up there and then i get it in empire
strikes back
they had to take out the shield
generator they had a shield the rebels
had a shield so they couldn't just
bombard them from space so they had to
send down the walkers
the empire is all about walking slow
flying fast you think that's their
slogan walk slow fly fast
the empire wants you to die horribly
because when people see you getting off
that ship and you're a stormtrooper
they're just like oh boy
leftovers but seriously join up it'll be
fun but yeah mando's ship just gets
obliterated wasted completely destroyed
i mean the ship is gone
that's a pretty big deal but boba fett's
like tell you what mando
since this is a star wars show we'll
team up with you because now fans can
make videos about how
mando and boba fett teamed up mando boba
fett
ming no when and they're gonna go get
bill burr they're forming a crew now
folks a crew because they need to get
baby yoda back because he was all
adorable and just
there with his little shackles the
shackles that are like as big as a
finger on my
but he's like a little shackle poor guy
he's the cutest little son of a [ __ ]
i've ever seen
other than my dogs those of you out
there who about to say otherwise
you hold those comments my dogs read
these things so yeah that that's where
we leave off is moth gideon
has baby yoda and he's like okay now we
have our source
whatever that means the source i'll get
to that in a second theorizing and such
and mandel's like we've got to put
together a crew and get little
baby yoda back groggoo grogu
yeah grogu grogu grogu goku
baby yoda stop with that his name is
grogu you can't call him baby yo anymore
mando has a name that i don't remember
and don't call him either
save your fake outrage for twitter
besides which his name is baba yaga
for those smart enough to remember and
so we see the plot of
the mandalorian and the point of
mandalorian again come into focus the
rabble of imperial zealots still
holding on to the empire have a plan
that plan involves
baby yoda being a host probably to
harvest his midichlorians
possibly to explain how palpatine came
back in the rise of skywalker possibly
to explain how someone cloned him i know
when in that cloning facility episode
the one with carl weather is where they
all go and they they raid that facility
and it's a cloning facility you see
like you know the messed up looking
clones in the glass i agree with you
i thought snoke and then my brain was
immediately like
don't need that don't do that i just
forgot
snoke because this is kind of like well
that's sequel trilogy i don't need to
hold on to that but and this is
possibly the point of all of it it's
quite possible they're using mandalorian
to not only do spin-off shows with boba
fett ahsoka tano whoever else
possibly to flesh out the world of the
sequel trilogy if that's
what they're doing that sounds like they
have their work cut out for them
but i can see it happening because in
star wars
there has been another scenario where a
television show
fleshed out a trilogy that some people
hated on myself
included and i thought it was impossible
for them to flush it out for me to give
a [ __ ] i was like oh clone wars don't
care
people were like no it really does flush
it i was like don't care
then i watched it i was like wow that
really does flush it out now should the
prequels have stood on their own not
needing a series
a television show to flesh it out sure
but it did and the end product is
actually something that's
interesting but that's where the
prequels and the sequel trilogy is where
it's different with the prequels you
still had the vision of one person you
had this lore building in this world
building imperfect yes flawed absolutely
so if you could flesh that out with
something you could have a really
interesting world there with the sequel
trilogy there's no
vision like that there's no world
building there's no lore building
it just seems like an unplanned series
of tug of war and lack of vision
so fleshing that out i don't think it's
it probably won't feel like it did with
the prequels and clone wars but again i
said prequels and clone wars was
impossible so anything's possible it
could happen and in 10 years time there
could be fans of the sequels who are
like
you should watch all these tv shows it
really flashes it out but
why at the thought of it tying into the
sequel trilogy i just
i get that feeling of like because
behind the mask
of every pessimist is the face of a
disappointed optimist and i'm the
disappointed optimist when it comes to
the sequel movie the advantage they do
have
is that there's such a chasm of time
between episode six and the sequels
that you don't have to tie it in but
that's the point is they should stick
with mandalorian being an interesting
show in its own right
and thus far that's what they've done
this would be kind of weird
that mandalorian this pretty well
budgeted show this
big budget show was created to explain
something that was clearly an
afterthought for episode nine palpatine
coming back oh well
well since you dropped that on us jj
abrams one week before we started
filming
exaggeration probably but yeah since you
dropped that on us
we'll make an entire show explaining
that which makes that line in rise of
skywalker that palpatine said that
he said in revenge of the sith it makes
it weird in context if this is where
they're going with it dark side of the
force is a pathway to many abilities
some
considered to be unnatural
and by dark side of the force i mean
science
cloning [ __ ] what else would it be
little thing i said just now
that's me dropping a line from revenge
of the sith to get people on board with
this mess
a cheap tactic to be sure but never
underestimate the power of nostalgia
and a reference but i do still think a
conversation between ahsoka and the kin
of anakin skywalker i think that would
be a good thing for everybody
all the characters involved it's funny
because rex was in the battle of endor
he was in the battle of endor like that
kid from iron man 2
is peter parker you know they're tying
stuff in retroactively but
point is canonically that's rex and so
rex was in the rebellion when luke
skywalker was
he must have recognized the name so he
might have been like i knew your father
in the clone wars
great jedi died tragically in the temple
raid very sad
luke can be like yeah totally how it
happened so maybe he got some stories
about anakin skywalker
also maybe rex is where luke learned the
name of darth sidious rex could be like
oh yeah
darth sidious he was the chancellor who
became the emperor who runs everything
now he
gave order 66. i remember very clearly
anyhow there's your story that's his
name darth sidious now you know who
knows but ahsoka was closer to anakin
than rex was you know that was a master
apprentice type
relationship you know they were the same
religion and
she was his apprentice so i feel like
she offers she has a unique
insight in anakin skywalker that she
could offer but i'm saying we'll see
where they go
if for nothing else mandalorian is
definitely that thing
where they're like we need to get star
wars back on track with
fans we need to have something
that shows people why the world of star
wars is actually cool so we'll see where
all of it goes but the point is
i am here theorizing talking about it
and interested to do so and that feels
good regardless i imagine ezra's coming
into it because
if thrawn is out there the implication
is ezra's too and why would they mention
thrawn
you know all right so the mandalorian
season two episode six team up of mando
boba fett and boba fett's half cyborg
apprentice
partner what did you think about it what
are your theories going forward as to
what they're doing with
all of it whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]